في هذه الحديقة الداخلية في أبو ظبي،
يقومون بزراعة أشجار الفاكهة من جميع
أنحاء العالم، وهي أيضًا مختبر لمجموعة
من العلماء من
معهد الابتكار التكنولوجي القريب الذين
يجرون أبحاثًا حول استخدام
طائرات النانو بدون طيار في
الزراعة.  هذا
هو ما يجعلني متحمسًا لهذه
الطائرة بدون طيار Nano، نعم لأنني متحمس جدًا
لها أيضًا، نعم، فهذه طائرة بدون طيار
من النوع الذي نعمل عليه في
مختبرنا، فهي تحتوي على معالج،
وتحتوي على كاميرا  ويمكننا بناء
برنامجنا وجعله يطير بشكل مستقل
ويعمل باستخدام هذه الحواسيب الطائرة الصغيرة، حيث يقوم
هؤلاء العلماء بتدريبه على
أداء العديد من
المهام، وما نحاول تحقيقه هنا
هو جعل المراقبة البيئية
ومراقبة المصنع مستقلة
وأكثر ذكاءً.  ما نفعله هو أننا نأخذ هذه
الكائنات الصغيرة التي تشبه
حجم اليد ونتركها تطير
حول النباتات حتى تتمكن من القياس في
أي نقطة وأي ارتفاع وأي زاوية وأي نوع
من أجهزة الاستشعار البيئية التي
تقرأ ظهور
الذكاء الاصطناعي  لقد جاء في
لحظة محورية في بحثهم اليوم، حيث يقومون
بتعليم طائرة Nano بدون طيار التعرف على
أشياء مختلفة مثل تحديد
فواكه معينة باستخدام الذكاء الاصطناعي
ورؤية الكمبيوتر، فهي قادرة على التعرف على أن هذه
موزة وأي نوع من المعلومات
هي تجمع كما نرى.  الأهم من ذلك كله هو
جمع الصور، ومن ثم
يمكنك إدخالها إلى الذكاء الاصطناعي الذي يمكن أن يخبرك بأن النبات قد
نضج، يمكننا اختيار النباتات
وأيضًا التحقق من
أمراض النبات حتى تتمكن من رؤية ما
إذا كان النبات يحتوي على أي أمراض على الأوراق مباشرة  المرض أو إذا
لم يكن لديه ما يكفي من الماء،
فهذا يعتمد على الصورة، بالإضافة إلى ذلك
لدينا أيضًا بعض
أجهزة الاستشعار البيئية، لذلك نقوم أيضًا بجمع
معلومات حول جودة الهواء ودرجة
الحرارة والرطوبة في المكان
ومدى سرعة نشر هذا
لدينا الآن أول نموذج أولي
للطيران، وعلينا تدريب الذكاء الاصطناعي الخاص بنا وبناءه
بطريقة تمكنه من فهم حسنًا،
هذه الفراولة تعمل بشكل جيد، وهي
جاهزة للحصاد، وهذا به بعض المشكلات
ولكن أعتقد أننا نهدف إلى أنه يمكننا الحصول على
أول نموذج أولي لإثبات مفهوم الطيران
في الربيع القادم
[الموسيقى]
العام